all right I'll try and Buzz through as
many of these as I can okay would I
rather be 50 or 15 for the rest of my
life uh I'd rather be 50 for the rest of
my life for sure 15 was like well number
one I can't drive and number two and
three and four and five like you just
aren't that wise
um and I don't have a lot of resources
so I'd much rather be 50 for the rest of
my life
um a burning man recap was requested
what do they need to know well
um Burning Man is uh like the hours are
different you know you kind of uh stay
up till you know the Sun or you know
somewhere between three four five six
seven a.m and um you know you don't get
as much sleep sleep a little bit I'm not
a big sleeper especially during the day
um and then you know it's just kind of
like riding your bike around so I'd say
you know it's like a different schedule
a lot of house music I didn't really
know that either
if you're a country fan you ain't gonna
find any you know Kenny Chesney out
there Jason Aldean it's going to be uh
it's going to be all house and beats and
music so
um be into that what I loved so much is
it's just like people in their truth you
know if they want to ride their bike all
day and go to Temple and cry fine if
they want to party literally all day you
can do that too uh but I'd say you know
go in with an open mind um go with some
friends so you have some people to go do
things with and um make sure you bring a
lot of twinkling lights because there's
a lot of riding your bike around at
night and with 80 000 people there and
everybody having a bike they all look
the same and you're gonna need lights so
you don't get driven over as well
um and uh have fun with the costumes but
I think it's such a great experience I
mean I think that it's just something
that if you have any level of curiosity
it's totally worth going at least once
most surprising interview of 2022 so
Josh Gates kind of surprised me I just
ended up having a lot of fun with him we
kind of bantered back and forth he's
he's really like a modern day in Indiana
Jones so
um or actually not even modern day
because Indiana Jones isn't real he's
like a real Indiana Jones so that was a
super fun we talked we talked about a
lot of the topics that I love to talk
about whether it be like travel or plant
medicine or any of those kinds of things
spiritual perspectives
um so that was great and then I thought
the other one that was surprising was I
loved the second so it's the second time
I've interviewed him but Dave asprey
um who's the like I can't even call him
The Godfather he's just literally the
father of biohacking he named it
biohacking because he came from the tech
world but Dave totally like normally
it's like a much more Health oriented
tips and tricks and big words that I
don't understand but we talked a lot
about spirituality and a lot about
energy and how this reality is working
and um so I thought that that second
Dave asprey interview was really cool I
really enjoyed that most inspiring
interviews of 2022. I'd say Zach Bush
he's also the second time I've
interviewed him as well um I guess this
is what happens when you've had a show
for a couple well three years almost um
so uh Zach is just like so deep and
again kind of similar to Dave it was a
lot more Health oriented when when I
interviewed him in 2019 about you know
cancer and how that works and you know
just a lot of different aspects of pure
heart more hardcore health and this time
it got more spiritual and it got much
deeper into how things really work in
the world and you know much more about
and is there a theme here like more
about energy and more about your mind
and your perception and
um I just uh I just I love that that
information is coming through because
it's uh it'll change the world so anyway
Zach's was a great interview and then I
think the other one that was super
inspiring was Michael Singer I mean I
was just so grateful that he did it he
doesn't do very many interviews he wrote
the book untethered Soul such great
information to some degree kind of
simple with the information like meaning
it shouldn't be complicated to
understand but just really powerful and
just like just a really really really
great guy so
um I thought that he he was very
inspiring as well okay uh my focus for
the next few years
um I'm gonna put a big focus on business
I you know I I obviously worked and
raced but then after that I kind of have
just like
let my creativity and my interests build
turn into businesses
but I'm not like the best boss like I
don't know exactly you know how to do
that I don't know numbers I'm terrible
like I I don't I'm not very good with
details so I just want to understand
better how to be a boss how to run
businesses how to make them more
successful
um so I'm gonna put a lot of focus in
the next few years into business and um
and also being out there a little bit
more I'm ready to do like another push
of um whatever I can do to help people's
confidence awareness and
um growth expand at the fastest and best
rate possible uh so I'm gonna I'm gonna
kind of jump in and see what else we can
so we could also see what else I can do
um so business is my focus for the next
few years
uh aspects of driver mentality that sort
of play that play into the spiritual and
personal growth side of things so
um I mean aspects of being a driver
include needing to be focused mind over
matter is also I mean to be in control
you need to know you can you need to go
into the corner with confidence and so
um I think that that plays into other
things too is having the confidence that
whatever's coming through energetically
or intuitively is true and that you can
trust that and you trust yourself I
think that that's an important driver
aspect that plays into spirituality
believing believing as a driver that
it's possible for you to go out there
and win and be successful just as much
as that there are
energies beyond our awareness
um or our consistent awareness for some
that are playing into our deeply into
our reality of how we experience this
life so
um having trust and believing is also
important places I'd like to visit oh
gosh this is like I could go on and on
um I'd love to go to Iceland I'd love to
go to
Patagonia Argentina Chile
um Bali Easter Island would be cool to
see
I'd like to go back to Egypt I'd also
like to see Petra which is nearby I
think Italy can you believe I haven't
really I don't think I've been to Italy
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen